everyone knows that apple was founded by
the two steves steve jobs and steve
wozniak steve jobs was the inspiration
and marketing side of the business while
steve wozniak was the brains behind the
business but what about apple's third
co-founder ronald wayne ronald wayne was
the adult of the business and made sure
that the steves didn't go too far off
the edge yet most people myself included
had no clue that ronald was even
involved in the creation of apple and
that makes sense as ronald left apple
quite early on so he wasn't there when
apple finally made it ronald is still
alive today though so what happened to
apple's unknown co-founder
taking a look back ronald was born on
may 17 1934 in cleveland ohio
we don't know much about his early life
but it seems like ronald was quite
passionate about engineering design and
product development he ended up
attending the school of industrial arts
in new york city and after graduation in
1953 ronald taught himself
electromechanical engineering at the
time electrical and computer engineering
were still very much in the early stages
so ronald's self-education was more than
enough to get him a job in the field
in 1956 ronald moved to california where
he secured a job as chief engineer at a
military electronics company where he
would work for 16 years
near the end of his career at this
company ronald became a bit
entrepreneurial and decided to start his
own business in 1971 at an age of 37
ronald started selling sloth machines
unfortunately this was a massive failure
and ronald ended up going into
significant debt ronald later recalled
that he discovered very quickly that he
had no business going into business he
was a great engineer and it was best to
just call it at that so ronald picked up
a new engineering job at a new startup
called atari and he would spend the next
year repaying the debt he had
accumulated
just as ronald thought he was completely
done with business though he would run
into two co-workers at atari named steve
jobs and steve wozniak wozniak says that
he admired ronald's experience with
starting a business and that he looked
up to ronald for advice on life ronald
was substantially older than both
steve's so he easily molded to becoming
a sort of mentor in the duo's lives
ronald often settled debates between the
two and one of these debates would
actually turn into apple
in march of 1976 steve jobs came to
ronald with the conundrum he and wozniak
had been working on developing circuitry
for a personal computer jobs wanted to
leverage the circuitry and build a
personal computer business and wozniak
was on board with this idea
however wozniak did not understand why
they couldn't just sell the circuitry
itself as well
jobs tried to explain that the circuitry
should be proprietary and that selling
it would just put them at a disadvantage
but wozniak didn't quite understand so
jobs wanted ronald to explain to wozniak
why he shouldn't sell the circuitry
ronald agreed and told the two to come
to his apartment on april 1 1976 to sort
out the issue when ronald explained the
situation to wozniak wozniak quickly
came around and agreed to not sell the
circuitry jobs was quite impressed with
how easily ronald was able to convince
wozniak and both the jobs and wozniak
looked up to ronald so jobs figured it
would be a good idea to get ronald to
join the company as well right after
ronald convinced wozniack jobs asked
ronald if he would be willing to join
apple ronald agreed and the trio would
make it official by incorporating the
company both steves owned 45 each while
ronald owned 10
this way ronald was able to break ties
between the steves after founding the
company ronald would get to work on
illustrating their first apple logo
writing the apple one manual and
drafting the trio's partnership
agreement while ronald worked on these
administrative tasks jobs went out and
started making aggressive deals which
made ronald quite uncomfortable
for example jobs took out a 15 000 line
of credit to buy materials required to
fill apple's first order that's the same
as a 72 000 line of credit today
to make things even worse apple's first
customer was a company called the bike
shop which was notorious for paying out
its vendors late and here's the thing
everyone involved in the partnership was
personally responsible for paying back
the debt now ideally wozniak and jobs
would be responsible for 90 of the debt
and ronald would only be responsible for
10 of the debt but the problem was that
wozniak and jobs were broke 20 year olds
with no assets so if things turned sour
wozniak and jobs would likely just file
for bankruptcy and it would be up to
ronald to pay back the creditors in
other words if their business did well
ronald only got 10 percent of their
profit but if the business did poorly
ronald will experience 100 of the
fallback given that ronald had just
recently spent a year digging himself
out of debt ronald wasn't willing to
take such a massive financial risk
something else that dissuaded ronald
from sticking around was the type of
work he had to do
as we previously discussed ronald's
passion was engineering and product
design but at apple ronald mainly just
worked on administrative tasks while
wosniak and jobs actually built the core
of the business ronald didn't feel like
it was his place to ask for a
product-oriented role in the company
either as he recognized that he was
quote standing in the shadow of giants
so 12 days after joining the company
ronald would respectfully part ways with
wozniak and jobs and renounce his role
in the company in return for his 10
percent stake in apple ronald received a
total of 800
or about 3 800 today wozniak actually
disagrees with this timeline claiming
that ronald didn't leave until a few
months after the company was started
either way though the consensus is that
ronald left very early on well before
apple found any sort of substantial
success
ronald stayed at atari up until 1978 at
which point he switched lawrence
livermore national laboratory meanwhile
jobs wasn't very fond of ronald's
decision and he would attempt to get
ronald back on board for quite some time
about a year after ronald's departure
though jobs finally gave in and moved
ensuring that there were no lingering
remains of ronald in the business jobs
paid ronald an additional 1500 and got
him to sign a quick claim deed which
basically meant that ronald gave up all
legal rights to apple or any of its
assets and with that it was official
ronald was completely out of the
business for a total of 2 300
or about 11 000 today later on in the
1970s ronald would start his own
business but it was nowhere near as
ambitious as apple
ronald opened a small stamp shop in
california but unfortunately he would
experience a number of robberies and
ronald would decide to move his business
across the border to nevada
jobs would approach ronald one more time
with a request to connect jobs with one
of ronald's friends
jobs was looking to buy the company that
ronald's friend owned but ronald refused
to relay the message
ronald felt that his friend should
retain control of his company and that
his friends should form an exclusive
licensing deal with apple as opposed to
selling out altogether
ronald later regretted this decision
citing that it was not his decision to
make
and that was the last time jobs tried to
contact ronald for a business
anyway ronald did take a few remnants
with him to nevada from his days at
apple ronald used a very similar logo
for his damn shop wayne's philatelics
ronald also still had the original apple
partnership contract paper which he
would sell in the early 1990s for 500
that same contract paper would end up
auctioning for 1.6 million dollars in
2011 and ronald did end up regretting
the sale as there was really no
financial risk to just holding on to the
contract and that brings us into the
billion dollar question did ronald
regret his decision to leave apple and
was he salty for giving up his stake
well the answer is no
i'm sure ronald wishes he stayed around
but he does not regret his decision to
leave ronald says that he made the best
decision he could with the information
he had at the time
moreover he didn't leave apple because
he thought the company would fail
in fact he thought the company would
succeed that's why he joined the company
but he knew that the road to success was
going to be extremely bumpy which he was
right about and he simply wasn't willing
to experience the ups and downs of the
journey ronald describes that leading
jobs and wozniak was like having a tiger
by its tail and that he was getting old
and couldn't keep up with that ronald
claims that the stress of staying at
apple would have likely resulted in him
becoming the richest man in the cemetery
so it wasn't like ronald was waiting for
apple to fail after he left or anything
in fact i think he's quite happy about
apple's success
considering this extremely mature
approach to missing out on one of the
biggest opportunities in history it's no
wonder why the steves wanted ronald
around
but what if ronald held on to a stake
how much would he be worth today
well apple currently stands at a
valuation of 2.4 trillion dollars
meaning that the entire 10 percent stake
would be worth 240 billion dollars but
it's completely unrealistic to expect
ronald to hold on to an entire 10
percent for 45 years
the best case scenario would be ronald
selling two percent for living expenses
and retaining an eight percent stake in
the company which would give him a net
worth of 192 billion dollars more
realistically though ronald would likely
hold a three to five percent stake today
which comes out to about 100 billion
dollars something else to consider is
that apple nearly went bankrupt in the
late 1990s so i don't think ronald would
have held it through that uncertainty
considering this ronald would have
likely down to stake in the 80s and 90s
even if he stuck around at apple meaning
that he would have cashed out for a few
hundred million dollars which is a far
cry from 100 billion dollars in any case
though sticking around at apple would
have resulted in a much better life for
ronald financially as ronald lives a
pretty modest retirement life today he
currently lives in a mobile home park in
nevada and makes some money on the side
selling stamps and rare coins and
playing penny slots in vegas
that's quite a stark contrast to what
his life could have been but i think
ronald says it best
what can i say you make a decision based
on your understanding of the
circumstances and you live with it would
you guys have left apple if you were in
ronald's situation comment that down
below
also drop a like if you respect how
ronald handled the missed opportunity
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions ultimately answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]
you